[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Will you join me
in welcoming to Google Anne
Fadiman and Lynn Stegner.
[APPLAUSE]
LYNN STEGNER: Well,
my first question
has to do with your father.
He died 18 years ago.
And I wonder if he
might be asking,
why did it take you so long?
ANNE FADIMAN: Ah.
Well, I don't think my
father would be asking
why did it take me so long.
Because he never
would have wanted
me to write this book
in the first place.
Because although it's a loving
memoir, hardly a Daddy Dearest,
it does contain
some things that I
know he wouldn't have
wanted me to write about.
Perhaps I should
explain who he is.
You know, but not
everybody does.
A recent review of the "Wine
Lover Daughter" was titled,
who was Clifton Fadiman?
And Adam Gopnik described
him with the adjective
"once-omnipresent."
And so that's both a complement
and, alas, a sad insult.
He certainly is not
omnipresent any longer.
He was mostly a writer.
But he was also--
at 28, he was the
editor-in-chief
for Simon & Schuster.
At the age of 29, he
was the book reviewer
for "The New Yorker."
At 34, he was the emcee
of a famous radio show
called "Information Please."
But he was mainly a writer.
And I think the
reason that it took
me so long was
that, first of all,
I couldn't have written
it while he was alive,
because I wouldn't have
wanted to hurt him.
And also I think
that his fame needed
to decline even more, year, by
year, by year since his death,
until it got to a point
where I no longer felt
that writing a book about
him would be standing
on the shoulders of his fame.
But rather trying to revive it.
Which put me in a far
more powerful role.
LYNN STEGNER: Well, I was
thinking about that yesterday.
And that this memoir
is a kind of-- you
are lending some of your
literary longevity back to him.
Because he wasn't able,
as you say in the book,
ever to complete a whole book.
And I wonder if you could talk
a little bit about why you think
he didn't do that whole book?
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, that's
such an interesting question.
I have dozens and dozens
of his books on my shelf.
But they're all either
collections of his essays--
he didn't consider
that a whole book.
It was a collection
of shorter work.
Or they're anthologies
that he edited.
Or they're books by others
that he wrote the foreword to
or the afterword to.
But he'd never
completed a whole book,
although he started several.
I think it was part of
his sense of insecurity,
that he didn't quite deserve to.
He deserved to review
books, and to write
forewords and afterwords to
books, and to edit books.
But never quite to write one.
An insecurity that I
think came from the fact
that he grew up poor in
Brooklyn at the beginning
of the 20th century.
Born to Russian Jewish
immigrants in 1904.
And although he
became someone who
seemed so patrician--
a friend of mine said,
oh my god, I always thought
that your father's family
must have dated back to Plymouth
Rock because of his voice.
And I think he felt like an
actor who was really, really
good at imitating people that
he would never truly feel like.
And that insecurity bled over
into his own life as a writer.
So the very fact
that I have written
some whole books, including
this one, that part
would really please him.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah, you talked
about his fear of the imposter
syndrome.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: Of being
a fake and a fraud.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: Even though he
had every pot on the stove
that you could have had on in
terms of the literary landscape
at the time.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes,
he was so successful.
One of his favorite evidences
of the reach of his influence
was that, when he was the
emcee of his big radio
show, "Information
Please," which at its peak
more than a tenth
of the US population
tuned into every Tuesday
night from 8:30 to 9:00--
by the way, just to see,
gee, more than a tenth.
Is that a lot?
I looked up the fraction of
the US population that tuned
in to the most popular episode
of "Game of Thrones," 1/20.
So he beat Game of Thrones.
But his favorite story about
the reach of his influence
was an occasion for a lawsuit.
He'd asked the radio audience,
in his inimitably plummy voice,
and now I would like to
ask the men in my audience
to close their eyes and see
whether they can remember
the color of their ties.
And unfortunately, one of his
listeners was driving a car,
and listening on the car
radio, and crashed into a tree.
And he was fine.
Otherwise this wouldn't
be a funny story.
But I think his
fender was destroyed.
LYNN STEGNER: Took a--
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
And he sued the show's sponsor.
And my father couldn't
have been more pleased.
Because that was
evidence of his affect--
LYNN STEGNER: The reach of his--
ANNE FADIMAN: --on
his listeners.
So yes, he was
extraordinarily successful
in any number of literary
jobs he held over the years.
But because when he was
small growing up, sharing
a bed with his two brothers over
a series of failed drug stores
that his father ran in Brooklyn
in poor neighborhoods, long
before Brooklyn became the
fashionable place it is now--
because he had grown up with
parents who came from Russia
and spoke un-grammatical,
heavily accented English--
English was essentially
a second language.
He said that he learned
it as if it were Sanskrit.
And although he never went
back to his earlier voice,
I think he felt like someone
who had learned to part
rather than been born into it.
One thing I found out when
I was researching this
was that his older brother--
who went to the same
public school in Brooklyn
that he had called Boys High--
had been the vice
president of something
called the Correct English Club.
And don't you think
it's poignant to imagine
all of these smart sons
of immigrants founding
a club that would help them
not sound like their parents?
LYNN STEGNER: I think
we still need that club.
I want to ask a question.
Just because growing up the
daughter of a well-known--
you resisted a temptation
that many descendants of fame
don't resist.
And that is you didn't
sanitize his life
when you wrote a memoir of it.
You really dealt with it
in an even-handed way,
including things
like his chauvinism.
I wonder if you would talk
about that as his daughter.
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh gosh, yes.
Well, reading my father's
literary reviews,
his putdowns of women
authors and readers
were more or less
a continuous series
of oinks from a really
completely irredeemable
male chauvinist pig.
On the macro level,
he was left wing,
and liberal, and in favor of the
Equal Rights Amendment, and sad
when it didn't pass.
But on the granular
level, he was really
condescending to women.
I came across a newspaper
article about a lecture
that he had once
given at a ladies
luncheon at which he said,
women are bad at conversation.
And they know
nothing about wine.
LYNN STEGNER: And this
was to a ladies luncheon.
ANNE FADIMAN: A ladies
luncheon at which
I am sure wine was served.
And perhaps I should say that
the reason that the book is
called "The Wine
Lover's Daughter"
is that it would have
been impossible for me
to write my father's biography
or a kind of grandiose memoir
about my father.
I needed a lens that
narrowed the task
to something that felt doable.
And books and wine were
the things my father--
LYNN STEGNER: Experience.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes,
they were the things
he loved most in the world.
As well as for him, the
most powerful symbols
of that cultivated, refined
life across the East River
that he aspired to when he
was growing up in Brooklyn.
And he wrote a lot about wine.
And of course, you used
to run a wine company.
And I've read that you have been
called an organoleptic freak,
because you are such a
remarkable wine taster.
I can't say that I
love wine myself.
And that's one of the
themes of the book.
But if my father
were sitting here,
I can guarantee you all
the rest of your questions
would just end up on the floor.
Because he would
want to talk to you
for an hour about great wine.
LYNN STEGNER: This was a way
out of escaping his origins,
to quote your brother, Kim.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: His
affection for wine
and his really deep exploration
of the world of wine.
How do you think--
would you like him
to know now what
you know now, which is
that you don't have,
genetically or
physically, a palate that
can appreciate wine?
ANNE FADIMAN: I'm not sure.
One of the chapters
toward the end of the book
is about my exploration in
the world of taste science.
It occurred to me that perhaps
my inability to love wine
wasn't a character flaw, as I
had assumed it was all my life.
From my father's
point of view, it
was as if I couldn't appreciate
art, or music, or literature,
all of which, thank god, I can.
But wine was in
that same category
of magnificent
human experiences.
And if you were a full human
being, of course you loved it.
But I found out by
taking a series of tests,
including genetic tests, that
I have a hypersensitive palate
that makes pretty much
everything taste too strong.
And in particular, I
have a genetic variant
that makes bitterness
in alcohol something
that tastes very intense to me.
I think he would have been
more likely to forgive me,
because it wasn't my
fault. But on the whole,
I think it would have been a
sad thing for him to learn.
Because he would have realized
that there was no hope.
He was-- he believed
in education.
He'd been educated
right out of Brooklyn.
And he kept hoping that if I
just kept tasting enough wine
that I would learn.
That is, children
don't like wine.
And yet, most do
when they grow up.
And so eventually, with
time, it would happen.
And I think he died still
hoping that that moment would
come for me.
And knowing that it
never would, oh my god,
I'm so glad I never
had to tell him that.
LYNN STEGNER: It would
have been a form of--
a disability.
ANNE FADIMAN: It
would have killed him.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah.
ANNE FADIMAN: An
absolute disability.
It was as if he had found
out that I couldn't see.
LYNN STEGNER: He lived in--
you know-- in New York.
And at a time when
psychoanalysis was in vogue.
And I wonder if given the
periodic depressions that he
went through and this
self-depreciation that he
was prone to, why he never
considered going into something
that everybody seemed to
be doing at that time?
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, I think a
really long psychoanalysis
would have done
him a lot of good.
And oh, the lucky analyst.
Because my father was
such a great talker.
He really could
have lain on a couch
and prevented an analyst from
sleeping, I think, for at least
a decade.
No, he never did that.
I don't think that he wished
to explore his darker corners.
Although he was honest
about their existence,
at least within the family.
Particularly in his later years.
I read a letter
that he'd written
to one of his closest friends
when he was in his 70s--
and he lived to be 95--
in which he said that our
culture makes it difficult,
if not impossible, for
children ever to really get
to know their parents.
Actually, that contained
a split infinitive.
And he would never have
split an infinitive.
So that is probably
not a direct quote.
But that was the idea.
And my book was a
refutation of that.
But the end of his life was
also a refutation of that.
Because he wanted to be
as transparent as possible
with his children, so that
he wouldn't die and have them
feel that they never
really got to know him.
So he was really forthright,
candid, and honest
about his flaws, and his
fears, and his insecurities,
all of which are in the book.
But of course, he didn't know
that I would be sharing them
with however many people.
LYNN STEGNER: 1/10
of the population.
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, yes, with 1/10
of the population of the United
States.
Yes, that's the number of
people who will buy this book.
I feel certain.
Especially after
this Google video.
LYNN STEGNER: Well, you say
that toward the end of his life,
he was trying to
pin himself down.
I love that phrase, because--
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: And he kept
journals in which he--
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: --explored his
own sort of machinations and old
motivations.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: So he did a
kind of his own analysis.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes
LYNN STEGNER: Self-analysis
toward the end.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes,
so when I said
that he didn't like to
explore the dark corners,
I should have completely
excepted the last couple
of decades of his life.
Because then he did start
exploring those corners,
not with the help of a shrink.
But he had terrible insomnia.
And he had two ways of
dealing with his insomnia.
He'd do word games in his head
in the middle of the night,
things like think of trees
beginning with each letter
of the alphabet.
He'd go, acacia,
baobab, chestnut.
And then he'd get
to x, y, and z.
And have a-- I guess
u for y would work.
He'd have a really hard time.
So I have a feeling that
these games kept him awake
rather than putting
him to sleep.
But they were a way to while
away the hours of 3:00,
4:00 in the morning.
But then he would
also sometimes--
he kept this journal on
little scraps of paper.
He'd turn on the light.
And he'd note a little
journal entry down.
And then it would be typed
up by his part-time secretary
the next day.
And I've read all of them.
I'm his literary executor.
So my house is just
full of his stuff,
which was one motivation
for writing this book.
I have 1,000 books of his.
And all his journal, and
letters, and tapes that I
made for a profile that I wrote
about him for "Life" magazine
when he was 80.
But those little
journal snippets were--
yes, a lot of them were about
his childhood in Brooklyn.
And a lot were about
the feeling that you've
mentioned of feeling
counterfeit, duplicitous,
like an actor,
someone who's going
to be found out any moment
and booted out the service
entrance.
Because he doesn't really belong
in the fancy gentleman's club.
LYNN STEGNER: Back to
the mudroom for you.
ANNE FADIMAN: That's
exactly right.
LYNN STEGNER: Well, one thing
I wanted to ask you about
was, because this memoir
is very balanced and not
a form of hagiography,
I'm wondering
if that process grew out of
your experience as a journalist
with requirements
of objectivity.
Or if it simply was that
you could trust your abiding
love for him to handle the
darker aspects of his life
and personality?
ANNE FADIMAN: Well,
I am a journalist.
But I don't think I was ever
an objective journalist.
That is, all of my best work
of reporting, I think, was--
is-- fair and accurate.
But not objective.
That is, I was never
a news reporter.
And so in my first
book, which was
about a cultural impasse between
a family of Hmong refugees
and their American doctors
called "The Spirit Catches You
and You Fall Down," I put
myself in as a character
and made it very
clear that I had
become close friends with
both sides of this conflict.
So that there would be no
attempt at objectivity,
although every
attempt, as I said,
at both accuracy and fairness.
But I do think that
when you're a journalist
you're not glossing over
the difficult stuff.
So it wasn't objectivity,
but completeness.
The desire not to paper over
things that are uncomfortable.
And journalism certainly
taught me that.
Partly because the things
that are uncomfortable
are the most interesting.
The second factor
that you named,
that my love for my
father would somehow
lead to triumph, even though I
certainly revealed his flaws.
And I think that was the
most important thing.
You really nailed it there.
I loved my father
very much, even
though there were
parts of him that were
disappointing and exasperating.
But I don't think it's worth
writing a book about anybody,
especially a parent,
unless you're
willing to go to those
uncomfortable places.
And I loved him.
And in memory, still
love him enough, in fact,
really quite superlatively,
that I was sure
that that love would come
through to the reader.
LYNN STEGNER: It does.
ANNE FADIMAN: Even
when I was dissing him.
LYNN STEGNER: I want to turn to
your relationship with writing.
And can you tell us something
about your writing process?
ANNE FADIMAN: Sure.
Well, it's funny that I'm
answering this question
at Google.
Because I wrote
most of this book
in a place as un-Google-like
as you could possibly imagine.
I wrote some of it at
the MacDowell Colony,
which is a literary and artists'
colony in New Hampshire.
But I wrote most of it at
a rented one-room cabin
in northwest Massachusetts that
had no internet, no landline,
and no cell service.
So I was completely undistracted
and alone with my father.
Who, by the way, liked luxury.
Would have hated
this cabin, which
also didn't have any hot water,
and didn't have a bathroom,
and other things.
It did have electricity.
But because I was completely
cut off from the world,
it was a lot easier to
feel that he was there.
Because nobody was
interrupting us.
And as I finished
each chapter, I
would put its name on a post-it
and array them vertically
along one of the wooden
posts of the cabin.
And when I put the final
one at the very bottom,
there was just room for the last
chapter after all those years.
There were tears in
my eyes, thinking
I'd finally got to the end.
LYNN STEGNER: Pinned him down.
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, I don't know
that I could ever completely
pin him down.
But I guess I sure tried.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah.
As a writer, are there
any particular battles
that you feel you've won
over the years of your work?
ANNE FADIMAN: I'm not sure
I ever feel I win a battle.
I feel that I survive a
battle, survive sufficiently
to come back and fight another.
Certainly as I've gotten
older, the ability
just to write a perfect sentence
without revision, that simply
comes delivered by
Amazon Prime instantly
by a winged muse, that muse--
you know, now it's sort
of more like UPS Ground.
So I have to do more drafts.
But my standards
haven't lowered.
So that ultimate
sentence has to be
just as good as it used to be.
It just takes a little
longer to get there.
But in the case of this
book, to write an entire book
about someone I knew so
well, and loved so much,
and missed so much, but who
was, in many ways, so imperfect,
was a challenge I
hadn't faced before.
And it's so much harder to write
about someone in your family
than someone outside your
family that you're reporting on.
LYNN STEGNER: You have
to sort of mature away
from their lived lives--
ANNE FADIMAN: Right.
LYNN STEGNER: --into lives
that are becoming almost mythic
in your--
ANNE FADIMAN: That's right.
LYNN STEGNER: --in
your heart and psyche.
ANNE FADIMAN: That's just right.
LYNN STEGNER: Your
husband is a writer, too.
What is it like living under the
same roof with another writer?
ANNE FADIMAN: My husband,
George Howe Colt,
also writes nonfiction.
So not only are we both writers,
but we're in the same genre.
And although I teach a
couple of days a week,
the rest of the week
I'm working at home.
And he works at home.
And we have lunch and
dinner together every day.
And we've often been asked, not
only why haven't you divorced,
but why haven't you
killed each other by now?
People assume that
there's rivalry.
But there isn't.
It was beautifully put
into words by a friend of--
late friend of mine,
Mark O'Donnell,
also a writer, who had
an identical twin, Steve
O'Donnell.
And they were both
comedy writers.
And at one point, one of them
was writing David Letterman.
And the other one was writing
"Saturday Night Live."
And when one of them
would get a Tony,
and the other one
wouldn't, somebody
said, Mark, when something
great happens to Steve,
are you jealous?
And he said, no.
I feel that Steve
won one for the team.
And so when George got his
National Book Award nomination,
oh my god, I wasn't jealous.
He'd won one for the team.
We also edit each other's work.
And George often reads
his work aloud to me.
So that's something
that will often
happen at the lunch table.
And I can't imagine
not being married
to another member of the club.
And so you, too, are
married to a writer.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah, but he
was mostly writing nonfiction.
And I was writing fiction.
So we had staked out separate
but equal territories.
ANNE FADIMAN: You
had your bailiwick.
With this sort of a
Berlin Wall between.
LYNN STEGNER: Well, there was--
no, a bunting board, let's say.
ANNE FADIMAN: OK.
Oh, a bundling board.
That's wonderful.
So people who don't know
what a bundling board was,
the Puritans would have
unmarried couples--
this actually sounds
sort of racy--
keep each other warm in bed.
But with something called a
bundling board between them.
So there could be no
physical contact whatsoever.
But yet you could
have conversation.
LYNN STEGNER: You could talk.
ANNE FADIMAN: A sort
of Pyramus and Thisbe
through the wall,
the hole in the wall.
So yes, the bundling board
between you and your husband.
That's just a--
LYNN STEGNER: But we also--
ANNE FADIMAN: That's
the loveliest metaphor.
LYNN STEGNER: We did edit
each other's work, too.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yeah.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah, there is--
that's a real lucky--
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: It's
a lucky circumstance
for a writer to have a
built-in home-grown editor
on the property.
ANNE FADIMAN: And
so inexpensive.
LYNN STEGNER: So
inexpensive, exactly.
This is a classic question.
But it's always an
interesting one.
And that is what writers or
books have most influenced you?
ANNE FADIMAN: Well, I majored
in the history and literature
of England in college.
I went to a college that
actually had a major called
history and literature.
And so the great 19th
century writers probably
influenced my prose style.
"Middlemarch" is probably
my favorite book.
And I think you can learn
more about human psychology
from "Middlemarch" than from
most psychology textbooks.
I recently read the--
did the audio book
for this book.
And it was the first time that
I had been the narrator of one
of my books.
And as I-- it turned
out to be much harder
than I had expected.
As I was in this little
studio, I found myself
saying to myself,
why does that writer
write such long sentences?
And why are there
so many parentheses?
And so I'm sure 19th
century British literature
was that influence.
But I'm very much
influenced, I guess,
by the great writers
of literary journalism.
John McPhee, Ian
Frazier, Joan Didion.
And McPhee has probably been
my longest-lasting influence.
I remember reading the
first part, the first third,
of "Encounters
with the Archdruid"
my freshman year in college.
And it was a genre that I
had never encountered before.
And there it was in
"The New Yorker."
And it was just as if a
tsunami had come over me.
And I thought, oh my god,
I would love to do that.
LYNN STEGNER: That's
what you want to do.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: That's a
great essay and great book.
I think I read it at
about the same time.
McPhee actually includes
one of your essays
as one of the 10 greatest
essays ever written.
It's an essay from "Ex Libris"
entitled "Marrying Libraries."
And it is one of
my favorite too.
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, thank you.
LYNN STEGNER: And I use it,
actually, in a class I teach.
But what I love about it most
is the unity of form, content,
and narrative voice.
It's just, everything
is fused beautifully
in that short essay.
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, thank you.
"Marrying Libraries"
was about what
happens when two writers, each
with a whole lot of books,
get married and have to
marry their libraries.
And first we lived together.
And then we got married.
And then we married
our libraries.
That was a much bigger step.
Because after we
mingled our books
and had to throw out the
duplicates and decide whose
would go, we really
couldn't get divorced.
I mean, that was a
far bigger commitment
than any marriage vows.
But yes, when John
McPhee put that essay
on his little list
of the best essays,
that was one of the
best moments of my life.
It was like God speaking
and tapping me on the head.
LYNN STEGNER: You get
to enter heaven now.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
I was in heaven at that moment.
And even just hearing you
say it just brings me back
to the moment when I
first found that out.
LYNN STEGNER: I have
a question about--
all of your books contain a very
rigorous, long sources section.
And I wonder if you could
footnote for us your devotion
to footnotes and sources.
ANNE FADIMAN: Sure.
Well, it's partly that I'm very
interested in being accurate.
So this book has no
made-up quotations.
Everything is verbatim or
very close to verbatim.
Everything my father says is
either quoted from something
that he wrote-- either
published, or from his journal,
or from a letter--
or something that I
taped or took notes on.
And so I wanted the
reader to know that.
Because most memoirs are
full of reconstructed quotes.
Because if somebody said
something 30 years ago,
how could you
remember it verbatim?
I also thought that
readers might be interested
in-- if they were
interested in a--
so there's a chapter
about my father's feelings
about being Jewish.
He encountered a great
deal of anti-Semitism
when he was young
and at Columbia.
And if anybody is interested
in reading about anti-Semitism
at Columbia during the
1920s, well, they're
in the sources at
the back of the book.
Also I love research.
And so maybe it's-- the--
I think the length maybe was a
specific response to something
that one of my
Yale students said.
As I was just about to
start the source notes,
I told this student, yeah,
over this winter break,
I'm going to work on the
source notes for my memoir
about my father.
And he said, a memoir?
Would that have source notes?
And I thought, oh my god, yes.
It took me years to do
all of this research.
So maybe I just
wanted a little trail
of evidence of all that sweat.
LYNN STEGNER: Well,
and you also write it--
there's also an essay that you
wrote called "Nothing New Under
the Sun," in which you let the
form mimic your attentiveness
to--
and it's a really irritating
piece to read, as wonderful--
I mean, it's supposed--
it's a gag, in a way.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yeah.
LYNN STEGNER: Because
every sentence
you write has a footnote.
ANNE FADIMAN: Is footnoted.
LYNN STEGNER: You have to
stop, and go down, and look
at the footnote, and
go back to sources.
And by the end of the essay,
we're shaking our fist at you.
ANNE FADIMAN: I wanted
you to shake your fist.
LYNN STEGNER: We were.
ANNE FADIMAN: That's an
essay about plagiarism
in "Ex Libris."
The idea being that everybody
always plagiarizes everything.
Because there's nothing
new under the sun.
And therefore, every single
sentence in the essay
had some source or another.
And everything was footnoted.
This book is not
footnoted, because I
didn't want to
interrupt the narrative
and make readers shake
their fists at me.
But I do have source
notes at the end.
LYNN STEGNER: Well, should
we take some questions
from the audience?
ANNE FADIMAN: Sure.
LYNN STEGNER: This is--
is this a good time, Dave?
Oh, OK, great.
Let's talk about-- go
back to wine a little.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes, your world.
LYNN STEGNER: Oh, I wanted you
to read a couple of excerpts.
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, sure.
LYNN STEGNER: So let's
hear that opening oakling.
ANNE FADIMAN: OK, yes, and I
have an oakling question then
for you.
So you're about to learn a term.
I'm really hoping that, if
this book does nothing else,
it introduces the word oakling
to the American vocabulary.
A few years ago,
I wrote an essay
about Hartley Coleridge, a
19th century British poet who
had the bad luck to be the
son of a far more famous poet,
Samuel Taylor Coleridge.
Hartley started off as
a celebrated wunderkind
and ended up a
penniless alcoholic
who often spent his days
in alehouses and his nights
in ditches.
A review of the only book of
Hartley's poetry published
in his lifetime allowed
that it manifested
no trivial inheritance
of his father's genius,
a sincere compliment,
if one that implied he
had no genius of his own.
But also cited an old
adage, the oakling withers
beneath the shadow of the oak.
I am interested in oaklings,
because I am one myself.
When writers beget
writers, there
are, of course, some advantages.
There are plenty of
books in the house.
There's an example
right under your nose
that words are a plausible
way to earn a living.
There's the intimacy that
comes when you and your parents
like the same things and
are both good at them.
But despite the
perks, oaklings face
a universally
acknowledged problem,
the mighty oak grabs
all the sunlight.
One solution is relocating
yourself as far as possible
from the shadow.
My brother and my half-brother
chose not to become writers.
They were thereby saved the
angst of Nick Harkaway, John Le
Carre's youngest son, who
said that becoming a writer
would feel as pointless as
standing next to a lighthouse
and waving a flashlight.
Like me, he became one anyway.
So an oakling-- the notion
that the oakling, the writer
offspring of the
famous writer parent,
is always going to be
smaller than the oak
is something that everyone in
my position struggles with.
So a terrible compliment to
give to the writer offspring
of a famous writer
parent is, oh, you're
a chip off the old block.
Because no chip has ever
been as large as the block.
So you're more or less an
oakling by marriage, Lynn.
Your father-in-law
was Wallace Stegner.
So partway through your
life, all of a sudden you
had a famous last name.
And you, too, were a writer.
What has that sort of
oakling-in-law-- dumb--
been like for you?
LYNN STEGNER: Well, mostly
it's been wonderful.
As I said, I had
built-in readers.
Both my husband
and father-in-law.
But it did hold me--
that tribe, that family tribe,
held me to a higher standard.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yeah.
LYNN STEGNER:
Other people held--
so my first book,
which was a first book,
necessarily flawed
in certain ways.
You know, I had my agent send
it out under my maiden name.
And then they asked-- actually,
it wasn't even my maiden name.
It was my first name
and my middle name.
And when they decided to
take the book, they said,
would you mind using
a different name?
Because they didn't--
and I said, well,
that's actually not my name.
And so they were very happy.
So there were advantages
and disadvantages.
ANNE FADIMAN: But I
admire you for making sure
that it was being
acquired by a publishing
house on its own merits.
That's such an
interesting story.
Because when I was
a young writer,
I considered using my
mother's maiden name.
That is, I considered
calling myself Anne Whitmore.
She had been Annalee Whitmore.
Because I also
didn't want anyone to
think that I was trading
on my father's name.
And I pondered it
for a few months.
And then I thought, but
I'm not Anne Whitmore.
I'm Anne Fadiman.
I'm a Fadiman just as much
as my father is a Fadiman.
That's me.
Why should I have
to change who I am?
LYNN STEGNER: You say,
he had my genes, too.
ANNE FADIMAN: That's right.
He had my genes, too.
Yes.
So it seems to me
that we shared genes.
They were verbal genes.
His two brothers also
were very verbal.
My brothers are very verbal.
We all shared the same genes.
So we inherited those genes
from great, great, great, great,
great grandparents.
And people who simply
say, oh, you've
got your father's genes,
as if there was absolutely
no creativity, or originality,
or even work on my part,
oh my god, it's exasperating.
But I'm so admiring that
you sold your first book
not under the name Stegner.
LYNN STEGNER: And then they were
very happy when they learned--
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh,
I'm sure they were.
LYNN STEGNER: Here's a question
I wanted to ask earlier.
And that is, your
fathers life effectively
bookends the 20th century.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yeah.
LYNN STEGNER: 1904 to 1999.
ANNE FADIMAN: There's
the 20th century for you.
LYNN STEGNER: There's
the 20th century.
So do you think
a Clifton Fadiman
would be possible in this
century in America today?
ANNE FADIMAN: No.
Oh, good question.
No.
My father's life as
a public intellectual
really was the cultural
life of the 20th century.
And I think that there
are two reasons why
if somebody like him
were alive today,
he would not be successful.
One was that my father
was essentially didactic.
He always wanted to be
an English professor.
Didn't get to be,
because Columbia said
that it had one spot for a Jew.
And it was going to his
best friend Lionel Trilling.
So much for his academic career.
But he was still
always the explainer.
He wrote a book about
the 100 greatest books
you should read in your life,
called "The Lifetime Reading
Plan."
He was a judge of the
Book of the Month Club.
That sort of
didactic explaining--
people between the wars, and
I would say also in the 1950s,
wanted to better themselves.
And people now don't
want anybody to say,
here are the 100 greatest
books you should read.
They might want to
read a self-help book
about how to make more money.
Or how to do better
on match.com.
But not what books to read.
So that didactic strain
wouldn't go over.
And the other was that, boy, he
was really an old, white male.
The "Lifetime Reading Plan."
100 books.
97 by men.
99 by white writers.
100 by Western writers.
So it seems to me that in
today's more diverse culture,
which I'm very
interested in myself,
he would be an anachronism.
And in some ways should be.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah.
Well, that makes sense.
But at that time,
our country needed
a cohesive unifying
voice of culture.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes.
LYNN STEGNER: After
the war especially.
ANNE FADIMAN: That's right.
He was it.
LYNN STEGNER: He was it.
ANNE FADIMAN: He was it.
LYNN STEGNER: And the
radio especially reached
that broader audience.
ANNE FADIMAN: That's right.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah.
ANNE FADIMAN: All of whom I
think felt somewhat elevated.
Because the level of wit
and repartee on "Information
Please" was so high, even
though a lot of their guests
were from show business.
They were all people
who were really smart.
And it was not a polarized time.
Just last week I happened
upon an old newspaper piece
about my father.
This isn't mentioned
in the book.
In 1940, he was
talking to a luncheon
of alumni of the University
of North Carolina.
And it was the fall.
And it was just before the.
Election.
And FDR was running
for his third term
against Wendell Willkie.
And one of the women
in the audience
said, who was your
favorite guest
ever on "Information Please?"
And expected him to say,
you know, Groucho Marx,
or Boris Karlov, or whatever.
And he said it was
Wendell Willkie.
Wendell Willkie was the
best-informed and most charming
man I ever had on the show.
Of course, I'm voting for FDR.
And the notion
that in those days
you could say something so
respectful about the guy you
weren't voting for
just made me sigh.
So that was the
kind of reaching out
to an audience to
try to bring them up
to his level of
education and civility.
So I think people
always felt that they
could stand a little taller
after listening to him.
But not as if they'd
had a boring 10th grade
English class.
Because he was
just so damn funny.
LYNN STEGNER:
Yeah, he was funny.
Back to the wine.
Prohibition was
repealed in 1933.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yes, that's right.
LYNN STEGNER: In 1935, he began
his extensive wine cellar.
ANNE FADIMAN: That's right.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah,
and so, in effect,
he was kind of a pioneer
in a country whose
wine fields had been laying
fallow for almost 14 years.
ANNE FADIMAN: 14 years, yeah.
LYNN STEGNER: So how
did he sort of get
that all going when there were
no sources of information.
ANNE FADIMAN: Well, he'd had his
first glass of wine in Paris.
Couldn't get one here.
Prohibition.
He was the editor
of Simon & Schuster.
He commissioned somebody
to write a book about wine.
But wine, of course,
was all French wine.
He learned about French wines.
And on the first day that he
felt ready to start collecting,
he bought 908 bottles,
as I discovered
when I found his cellar book.
And Chateau Lafite Rothschild
cost $1.75 a bottle.
LYNN STEGNER: Alas.
[LAUGHTER]
Should we take some questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh god, you'd
have to be a billionaire.
And of course, many of those
wines that he bought in 1935
were from 1929.
Which, of course you know,
was probably the greatest year
for wine ever.
Nobody quite knew that yet.
Because it was only
six years earlier.
The Lafite Rothschild
I think was '28.
But I know that he bought
Chateau Margaux for $25 a case
from 1929.
That's $2.08 a bottle.
AUDIENCE: That's baffling.
So--
ANNE FADIMAN: Is there
a question there?
Oh.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'll pass it.
On.
So this question is for Anne.
So I know that you mentioned
that the 18th century
British writers really
influenced your style.
ANNE FADIMAN: 19th century.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
19th Century.
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, the
18th century people
were really dry and dull.
The 19th century with the
Romantics and the Victorians,
oh, very different.
AUDIENCE: So sorry,
19th century.
But what I was actually going to
bring up was the 18th century.
So I know that you have a
little bit of an affinity
for the Romantics.
And you have an essay about
Samuel Taylor Coleridge.
I was wondering
if you could maybe
talk about your
appreciation for him.
ANNE FADIMAN: Sure.
So Samuel Taylor
Coleridge mostly
writing in the
early 19th century.
There was a group of--
among the lake poets.
William Wordsworth was
also in that group.
He was the father of
Hartley Coleridge,
the poet I mentioned
earlier who was essentially
called an oakling,
because he grew up
withering beneath the
shadow of this great oak.
And I'm particularly
interested in Coleridge's life,
because he spent much
of it running away.
My essay in a book called
"At Large and At Small"
is called "Coleridge
the Runaway."
And he ran away by
becoming an opium addict.
He ran away from his marriage.
He ran away through
procrastination.
And at one point
he just ran away
from England, where
he had disappointed
a great many people
personally and professionally.
And ran away to
Malta, where he worked
as a sort of junior diplomat.
And yet, despite the fact
that he was so disorganized
and could never face
any difficulties,
he was incredibly productive and
one of the greatest poets ever.
And I'm so interested
in process that I
was fascinated to
think about, how
could you be so great
and so productive
when you were so messed up?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'd
like to ask if--
I'll preface this by
saying my hobby is writing.
I'm working on a bunch
of short stories.
ANNE FADIMAN: Great.
AUDIENCE: I've started a new--
well, I haven't finished
my first novel yet.
But I started another
one fresh for NaNoWriMo.
I'd just like to know if you
have any advice for aspiring
writers?
ANNE FADIMAN: Sure.
Well, I was talking about
this in the car here.
And I was lucky enough to
have a marvelous author
escort driving me in my
car who's sitting here.
And she said, well, I was
writing something for my work
just yesterday.
And it wasn't really that good.
I just don't think I
could ever be a writer.
And I said, if you wrote 20
drafts like me you could.
And I think most
people don't know
how good they could possibly be,
at least on the sentence level.
Because they write a
sentence in an email.
And they go, eh, that's OK.
Well, my emails aren't
that great either.
Because I'm not rewriting
the sentence 20 times.
But I also think that the best
advice for an aspiring writer
beyond rewriting, and
rewriting, and rewriting
is reading, and
rereading, and rereading.
I've always felt that if they
had a psychology experiment,
and they put one guy
on a desert island
with an unlimited amount
of paper and pencils
for five years.
And then on the
next island they had
a guy marooned with an unlimited
library for five years--
I'm not suggesting
this as an experiment.
I think the psychological
profession probably
would ban it.
But I'm convinced that the guy
on the island with the books
would probably be a better
writer at the end of five
years, even though he hadn't
been able to write a word.
LYNN STEGNER: That brings me
to a question I wanted to ask.
And that is, how does
teaching affect your writing?
ANNE FADIMAN: I teach
creative nonfiction at Yale.
It mainly distracts
me from my writing.
Because it means I can
write only in the summers.
But my students'
writing is so good
that I'm convinced
I'm contributing more
to American literature
by teaching writing
for most of the
year than by writing
more books during my lifetime.
Because my students become
such marvelous writers.
It's not that my teaching makes
them such marvelous writers.
They're already on
that trajectory.
But if in a few
cases I could give
that final nudge that
might make them say,
yes, I have the
courage to do this.
Because somebody said
I was really good.
So they're so good
that they inspire me.
And they keep me fresh.
As I get older, they
stay the same age.
It's amazing.
The new crowd comes in.
And they're just forever young.
And they keep me young.
It's sort of--
LYNN STEGNER: And
in the conversation.
You're still in
that conversation.
ANNE FADIMAN: Oh, in
the conversation, yes.
They never shut up.
And they never let me shut up.
And that's the best
thing about it.
AUDIENCE: OK, I have
one more question.
This one's for Lynn.
So I'm going to actually ask
you the same question that you
asked Anne, which is who
are your favorite writers,
and what is your favorite book?
Where do you draw
inspiration from?
LYNN STEGNER: I'm still filling
in gaps in my education.
And so I tend to read
books, great books, that I--
they're all on your
father's reading list.
But American writers that
really have influenced me
are William Styron,
Hemingway's short stories.
Not his novels.
But then Dostoevsky.
I read all of the world's,
I think, existential writers
for a period of time.
Sabato and Camus, of
course, and others.
So I think it's
all over the map.
But I don't read a lot
of really new fiction.
It's like waiting for a new app
to go through 0.1, 0.2, 0.3.
I wait a while before
I pick up new books.
ANNE FADIMAN: Or
like a great vintage.
A really great wine is not
at its best in the year
that it's produced,
as you well know.
You have to wait
until it matures.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah, and goes
through its awkward periods.
ANNE FADIMAN: Goes through
its awkward periods.
LYNN STEGNER: Yeah.
ANNE FADIMAN: Yeah, Chateau
Mouton Rothschild sort
of version 0.01, 0.02--
LYNN STEGNER: Right, right.
ANNE FADIMAN: 0.03.
LYNN STEGNER: Wait
until you get to 0.3.
Yeah.
How are we for time?
SPEAKER 1: I think we're OK.
LYNN STEGNER: OK.
Any other questions?
SPEAKER 1: All right, well--
ANNE FADIMAN: May I
just end with something
about my father and Google.
I was talking with
my brother Kim
before I came out
here to California.
And I said that I was going to
be doing this talk at Google.
And he reminded me that
my father's math professor
at Columbia-- about whom he
told many stories when we were
growing up-- was Edward Kasner
who invented the term Google,
spelled G-O-O-G-O-L.
And my brother reminded me
that we'd heard from our father
that Kasner had been on a walk
with his young nephew, Milton.
And Kasner had
said, Milton, what
would be a good word
for a really big number.
Let's say one
followed by 100 zeros.
And little Milton,
said, what about google?
It was a made up word.
Kasner spelled it G-O-O-G-O-L.
But that was the inspiration
for Google.
And my father had a
marvelous mental game,
another mental
game, that he would
play inside his head in
the middle of the night
when he had insomnia.
And it was called, I shook
hands with Shakespeare.
And he would imagine
somebody like Shakespeare
who had lived a long time ago.
And he would imagine
people that he
had known shaking hands with.
And then somebody
that that person
might have known, going back
to the previous generation.
Somebody that that
person might have known.
And tried to get himself
all the way back to sort
of shaking hands virtually
through the centuries
with some great writers.
And so now that all of you
are here listening to me,
and I am the daughter
of my father,
and my father was the
student of Edward Kasner,
I feel that Google is
shaking hands with Google.
[LAUGHTER]
LYNN STEGNER: You
are the missing link.
ANNE FADIMAN: I am missing link.
I have restored it.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
thank you, Anne, Lynn.
Thank you for coming.
Let's give them one
more round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNE FADIMAN: Thank you.